Lana Blakely has over 1 million
subscribers on YouTube and it was this
single thing that helped her create
viral videos I know for sure that I
would not have a YouTube channel had not
been journaling because that's where I
do so much of my thinking and so much of
that is what creates the videos is
things that I've been writing about and
thinking about by writing about it and
so Memoir journaling is just a concept
that I made up which is basically let's
say you go on a first date with someone
and you want to write a memoir generally
entry about it instead of being like
yeah we grabbed a cup of coffee it was
fun
um you go into more detail of like okay
what was the atmosphere were you sitting
at a cafe and what was the feeling there
and what could you see and was there
music playing and do you think that
music affected the mood and kind of
going into too much detail uh just to
really bring that moment to life and
what it's helped me do is pay more
attention I think in everyday life it's
kind of like a stop and smell the roses
kind of thing in a nutshell